comprenez vous que l'on puisse voter
l'hexagone il ya énormément de oui c'est
fou matthieu delormeau lui laisser la
peau cartouches mans merci alors qui dit
oui et pourquoi parce que c'est très
intéressant de voir le nombre de wii ça
veut pas dire que vous votez à moins
bien entendu que je le dis aux
téléspectateurs voilà c'est juste vous
comprenez mon puissent voter zemmour
delphine toi tu comprends oui oui je
peux comprendre parce qu'en fait les
gens n'ont plus confiance dans les
politiques parce qu'on se dit que chaque
quinquennat c'est la même chose au final
et surtout celui ci un de maquereaux n'y
a jamais eu autant de manifestations il
y avait les gilets jaunes maintenant il
ya tous les par rapport aux vaccins et
les antis passer tout ça et a jamais eu
autant de personnes dans la rue qui
manifestent leur mécontentement et donc
quelque part zemmour il représente passé
politique dont on dit qu'ils sont tous
pourris il représente quelqu'un du
peuple mais qui s'y connaît en politique
donc le petit côté émergents celui qu'on
avait pas vu venir c'est un peu le
syndrome de macron parce qu'on l'avait
pas vu venir non plus et c'est cette
fraîcheur que les gens ont aimé et puis
quelque part
eric zemmour aussi ça fait des années
qu'ils analysent la politique qu'il l'a
vulgaris pour les gens et donc du coup
on a l'impression qu'il a pu tirer le
meilleur de chaque politique pour
peut-être nous donner la conclusion quoi
alors il fait de sorties chaque semaine
eric zemmour notamment là en ce moment
c'est un jour une polémique il divisera
coup certains l'adorent mais d'autres le
détestent pour ses prises de position
mais bizarrement à chaque fois qu'il
fait une sortie il renforce son
électorat et vient en grignoter un petit
peu plus chez marine le pen et chez les
républicains c'est vrai qu'il va falloir
qu'ils républicain bouge un peu parce
que là c'est vrai qu'ils sont pris en
étau entre
entre les deux le regard des derniers
exemples en date sa sortie sur les
élèves transgenres lors de ce nid
interview avec l'excellente laurence
ferrari qui embrasse si un enfant un
enfant je le répète vient dire ah bah
non je suis pas une fille choix garçons
on doit on doit le prendre en cause on
doit ne plus l'appeler l on doit on doit
admettre son nouveau prénom et pis quoi
encore c'est cesser écrit vous savez
c'est vraiment criminel aux états unis
il y ait l'inique de transition de gens
pour des enfants de 3 ans vous appelez
ça comment grosse et moi j'appelle ça
les expériences du dr n'est pas le cas
en france non c'est pas le temps
interdire monsieur blanc caire monsieur
carrière à double saut genre
d'expérience alors vous allez voir on va
voir plusieurs sorties d'eric zemmour
autour de ce débat c'est donc la
question est simple comprenez vous que
l'on puisse voter eric zemmour je
voulais dit il à 17% dressons hadji
serait au deuxième tour face au
président de la république david tu
comprends pas ça leur toit et de la
france insoumis forcément tu comprends
pas mais tu comprends pas on sait que tu
voterais pas pour réalmont mais est-ce
que tu comprends pas qu'ils aient des
gens qui puissent se tourner vers lui
parce qu'ils sont tournés vers plein de
gens et ils disent à chaque fois ils
n'ont pas la solution c'est ça le danger
moi je comprends que des gens qui ont
peur ouais je comprends pas pourquoi ils
votre aisément mais je comprends que des
gens qui aient peur mais moi si on a
peur aura de quoi si on a peur on vote
pour on est paralysée par napoléon donc
en fait on arrête de réfléchir et on va
taper faire sortir et le problème c'est
que si tu veux moi ce que ce que
j'essaye de faire comprendre aux gens en
ce moment c'est que faut arrêter d'être
tout le temps défensif par rapport à ce
qui dit faut aller chercher un peu qui
sait ce monsieur le sait on parle quand
même de quelqu'un qui dit respecter des
terroristes c'est ça qu'il dit c'est à
dire que moi je vois pas ce qui est
respectable à prendre un camion de
panique il souhaiterait arrêter d'aller
aidé à l'écraser des gamins ya rien de
respectable à ça quand tu entres dans
une salle de spectacle avec des
kalachnikov sur armés qui tuent des
innocents il n'y a rien de respectables
sa vision du pays allaient pas
respectable et le problème là dedans en
fils la force de laisser se déchaîner et
ses danseuses parler de tout ça il ya
plein de gamins dans le pays qui se
disent mais je suis dans mon pays là
c'est ça la vérité et les faits moi ce
que je dis c'est que ce fonds devrait
commencer à faire c'est déjà reconnaître
l'histoire de nos pays mois jade moi
j'aime mon pays tu vois et et mon pays
c'est aussi dès 1870 les turcs aux des
tirailleurs algériens qui arrive qui
font la guerre aux pouces et encore
leurs descendants dans ce pays là qui se
disent mais qu'est-ce que je fais là
c'est la première guerre mondiale ses
1700 mohamed qui meurent au combat c'est
la seconde guerre mondiale la bataille
de monte cassino leurs problèmes et
aujourd'hui
avant l'été de pouvoir et le chien je
n'ai jamais pensé à une question est une
question déjà de fierté mais oui
c'est à dire aux gens mais je la jette
pas les français s'y ajuste à des gens
je dis juste à des gens que il ya des
français notamment dans les dom tom
enfin dans les territoires d'outre-mer
maintenant qu'ils sont français depuis
1848 et leurs descendants sont victimes
alors c'est pas eu de gueule ni d'audace
en
main sur l'argent moi je veux bien qu'on
en parle mais je veux dire eric zemmour
il propose quoi aux gens qu'on pas
d'argent cp c'est que quelqu'un peut me
donner sa proposées dont j'ai joué
là-bas c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui j'ai
rénové aujourd'hui david aujourd'hui on
le voit on le voit comment comment se
construit la campagne aujourd'hui le
principal sujet et c'est ça qui est
inquiétant c'est l'insécurité c'est ça
qui est chez les jeunes chiens notamment
on croyait que ça touché énormément les
personnes plus âgées aujourd'hui ceux
pour qui la sécurité est la priorité ce
sont les jeunes je les ai vues sur ce
plateau mais oui mais la personne qui
dit ce mois là le truc qui compte le
plus pour moi c'est l'insécurité c'est
pas et donc c'est vrai que il a été
malin là dessus ce qui ne parlent que de
ça oui mais c'est moins sûr ça c'est non
mais non mais d'habitude pourquoi je te
dis ça parce qu'il ya des réalités donc
à un moment il faut voir aussi où joue
la campagne le quotidien se joignait
carlos mamani migrants j'ai pas de
sujets tabous juste on parle
d'insécurité tempe les gens ont peur
chez pas des sdf disons que les gens ont
peur ils ont peur des sdf l'année
pourquoi pas est ce que vous savez qu'à
sdf sur quatre qui est passé par l'aide
sociale à l'enfance c'est à dire qu'en
fait on a fait passer des gamins dont
l'état devait s'occuper qu'ils ont
abandonnée à partir des différents
ça dépend de la racaille qui accueille
des jeunes arrêtés non mais c'est pas
grave j'en avais
l'insécurité y a pas de preuve que droit
mais ce qu'on va régler le problème en
mettant des flics partout moi je crois
pas moi je crois pas captain on a on a
toutes fermées policiers
ils ont ils noté ce label fitoussi
yoplait david alors ça va gueuler jean
michel mr ouai il comprend qu'on puisse
voter rixe et bien sûr est ce qu on
compte au mieux quand je viens
d'entendre l'avis de sa qui est toujours
sur des visions complètement archaïque
de la belgique qui veut que si on vote
pour zemmour a sous la semelle c'est un
vote par défaut à vote parce qu'on a
peur non il y aussi des votes par
conviction c'est que les gens votent pas
ce qu'il fera porter pour les autres une
histoire les gens votent pour oser mots
parce qu'ils y pensent moi je sais pas
si j'allais voter pour lui que c'est un
homme qui pense qui dit qu'ils disent
qu'ils pensent qu'ils phrase qui pense
vous était raccord et desservir la
collection ils ont tellement marre des
épaules m politi girouette il veut la
leader et sa leader qui n'est pas usé
par un passé politique sulfureux comme
beaucoup d'autres voilà qui
est évidemment bien sûr et voilà et là
ils se disent un homme voilà qui fera ce
qu'il dit et on
dirait eric zemmour a également fait
beaucoup réagir cette semaine avec une
autre sortie cette fois sur les immigrés
il a demandé l'arrêt total de
l'immigration en france qu'elles soient
légales oui les regarde ni 1 275 mille
entrées légales par en plus les 130
milles droit d'asile dont 80% sont des
bouquets bellachonne ne part vous
connaissez donc on a à peu près une
ville de nice plus qu'une ville de nice
tous les ans qui rentrent et une ville
de paris au bout du mandat demain donc
on arrête cette immigration on arrête
complètement d'accord moratoire sur
l'immigration et la sueur loiret avait
marre elle augmente amical on arrête
mais entend un asile à l'extérieur ok
sois là et eric zemmour voilà c'est
encore une autre sortie on va en voir
plusieurs gilles verdez vous vous ne
comprenez pas non non non non je
comprends pas parce que c'est pour moi
basée à chaque fois sur le mensonge
mensonge historique mensonges des
chiffres mensonge contre les musulmans
mensonge quand il dit que les lobbys
vous montriez l'extra juste titre que
les lobbys lgbt entre à l'école donc non
je comprends pas je n'arrive même pas à
admettre mais je ne comprends pas non
plus parce que en fait c'est une vaste
hypocrisie le seul intérêt de zemmour
c'est lui a pas de conviction politique
derrière c'est pour moi de
l'opportunisme donc je réponds un grand
nom alors à discuter avec nous vous êtes
rappeur journalistes et vous vous allez
voter eric zemmour peut-être pourquoi
pourquoi parce que je trouve qu'il est
cohérent sur beaucoup de choses d'abord
et je trouve qu'il ya énormément de
mépris envers lui et envers l'aiea la
plupart des gens qui le soutiennent et
qui le représente
il nie la réalité qu'est ce qui vous
plaît si eric zemmour ce que vous avez
fait avec soirée catch j'ai 26 ans voilà
26 ans est vrai que et qu'est ce qui
vous plaît déjà il est cash ouais il
prend pas de gants malgré ce qu'on pense
m'a déjà et il a une bonne connaissance
des quartiers populaires et tous quand
même un mec a grandi dans le 9 3 il
arrivait en tant qu'immigré avec sam if
d'accord avec sa famille au bailleur je
veux dire je veux dire c'est pas non
plus la plupart des gens qu'on voit
aujourd'hui dans la politique c'est des
mecs ils sont fait sponsoriser depuis le
plus jeune âge c'est des rentiers est ce
que tu dis aux gens qui disent eric
zemmour il nous fait peur je leur dis
qu'il faut pas en avoir peur en fait on
est en france on est dans un pays qui
est bien foutu les gens ils sont pas
chtarbé aux dernières nouvelles
je pense que s'il est élu la plupart de
ces trucs même pour l'instant y'a même
pas de programme déjà bien avec 17
points n'a pas de programme ouais c'est
vrai en plus il a mis un programme c'est
en tout cas une certaine émulation
autour de lui en faire une certaine
comme on dit une certaine
enfin une adhésion l adhésion voilà de
lui vante à ses idées oui et moi je
pense juste qu'il n'est pas assez
informés en fait sur sur l'islam par
exemple ce qui n'est pas assez informés
même et c est ce que vous vous êtes vous
êtes musulman oui vous êtes pratiquants
oui et ça vous dérange pas tout ce qui
est dit sur l'isla certaines fois ci
mais je trouve que c'est de la
maladresse et qu'il est juste mal
informés on est juste là pour l'armada
hilal mauvaises herbes il a le mauvais
entourage y sentons mal aux
gens des jeunes à eghezée mon moi ils
chantent ils changent d'avis que
certaines vous lui diriez quoi
déjà je lui dirais qu'on est très proche
par exemple à ce qu'il disait sur les
lgbt à l'école madame mais pense la même
chose que moi normalement si c'est une
vraie musulmane pratiquante alors déjà
on n'est pas là pour parler
à léo faire des commentaires surtout
amélioré dans un parking un écho db tout
à l'heure ils répètent tous sont d'y
arrêter de marmonner dans votre barre
pour les voitures mal garées au moins
200 mères si ça marche je vais à la
mosquée c'est roger une famille
musulmane album je vais dire la plupart
des musulmans tradi tu vois que je
connais on va dire qu'on va même
qualifié de radical des fois ils sont
plus proche des catho de la manif pour
tous cas échant genre clairement c'est
pas on n'est pas si loin parce que c'est
vrai que parce qu'on voit ce qu'ils
disent sur le vice la bêtise a sonné
s'est étonné gilles devoir ray mine de
rien à nice a été pour pour eric c'est
la médecine et j'entends avec avec
intérêt et c'est vrai que là pour moi
c'est problématique parce que je trouve
que vous légitimez ce qu'il dit alors je
sais pas quelles sont vos arrières
pensées éventuelle mais sur les
musulmans excusez moi c'est quand même
très violent ça oui maintenant j'ai moi
même été blessé par certaines parce
qu'ils
savent que vous bien sûr mais pas qu'ils
connaissent toutes les idées politiques
ils sont huit secondes à des débats
animés c'est super pagne elle même elle
est très à gauche vous avez des débats
mais je me sens moi je suis désolé mais
vous allez vous faire plumer enfin ces
sacs bien se passer c'est que eric
l'alignement exécutif est il le dit
c'est l'islam est incompatible avec la
goana ratifié quoi donc donc vous allez
vous faire plumer 1 à la fin maintenant
ils vous feront tout je ne sais pas je
voudrais conseil d'état quand tu savais
comme ces discussions mais l immigré un
arc légiste en aveyron de les renvoyer
et en plus vous voyez les centres précis
mme patti nous sort l'histoire des
villes qui arrive et que c'est en mai
mais un étudiant sur trois quarts et
déjà c'est un étudiant on n'a plus envie
que la france elle rayonne dans le monde
en fait c'est bon c'est
quand j'écoute les liens
se balader je sais pas moi vers le
jardin elle par exemple ces conneries et
là le 19e city de se balader un peu
là-bas vous voyez ce qu'elle apporte une
crise les gens à l'heure mais même dans
même dans des quartiers moi je connais
des dix lots simple touche pas un mec
moi je promets que de noyer ou quoi je
connais des deals hausse j'ai un casier
judiciaire bah bravo non mais c'est pas
une fierté d'ailleurs mais je veux dire
par là que je connais un peu des gens
dans le mieux clairement même un terrain
mais qu'un gérant de terrain voilà il a
des problèmes avec les immigrés avec les
clandestins qui viennent vendre des
fausses marlboro se droguer et arraché
des pauvres dames maintenant au lieu
d'embaucher des guetteurs et l' embauche
des vigiles
souplesse à nice vous donc ce qui vous
plaît chez eric zemmour c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est qu'ils
fassent beaucoup beaucoup autour de
l'insécurité vous allez vous sentir plus
en sécurité avec eric zemmour au pouvoir
c'est ça avec le haut avec un autre mais
enfin avec quelqu'un en tout cas qu'ils
allaient comment dire qu'ils allaient
les coraux pour être un peu vulgos de
parler et de dire les choses en fait 2
un moment tu sais nous par exemple moi
je suis algérien aussi j'ai la double
nationalité chez nous on aime bien les
hommes d'autorité on aime bien ça je
vois qu'il ya en algérie en mai qui fut
membre est dans la rue comme ça on
dirait qu'à passer votre enfant doit
clairement aux abris la police soit plus
répressives peut-être pas plus
répressive mais qu'ils aient plus de
commentaires de la liberté c'est ça donc
donc vous pensez que l'état doit laisser
plus de liberté à la police pour qu'elle
soit encore plus épurés brest par
exemple je pas si vous avez vu bac nord
oui mais voilà elle s'enferre dans le
spoiler 13 ans c'est une histoire vraie
il se retrouve à faire une collègue de
shit parmi des clients parce que leur
hiérarchie elle va pas leur fils est un
peu cheap pour payer un indic et au
final c'est eux qui se retrouvent à
aller en taule
parce que leurs commissaires il les a
lâchés comme en défense que bâle alors
c'est l'histoire quand même de gens de
policiers qui sont poursuivis par la
justice pour fo vision il faut pour
extorsion
david annie j'aimerais qu'on écoute
qu'il ya des gars qui étudiante en droit
qu'à 24 ans qu'on connaît bien dans
l'émission lire quand tu entends tout ça
est ce que ça fait rire tout est ce que
eric zemmour te fait peur alors ce qui
me fait peur non mais ce qui m'inquiète
c'est des discours que j'en change
surtout à nice il explique qu'il veut
voter pour eric zemmour parce qu'il est
cash parce qu'il a grandi dans le 9-3
aux il dit des choses mais il les fera
pas avec lui avec arnaud je me sentirais
plus en sécurité en fait c'est sur du
vide concrètement que se basent adapte à
conviction que là tu fais du tir
hippiques est en train de choisir des
morceaux de ce que jean crinon et
priscilla déni mais le mot pour mot ce
que tu as dit non non je suis pas du
tout malhonnête sur ça et moi parce que
je comprends pas c'est pour ça ça
t'évoque quoi un musulman qui votent
pour eric zemmour mais en fait c'est
franchement je suis désolé pour mes non
c'est ouais pour masser incompatibles
mais c'est même pas ça qui m'inquiète
c'est qu'en fait ils abattent résolument
si en face de moi j'avais un musulman
qui m'a apporté 3 arguments on aurait pu
discuter mais franchement il n'y a aucun
qui me convainc alors tout ira bien
voulu mais c'est convaincre mais ça
marche pas c'est évident
lorsqu'elles sont cordiales pour le
faire changer mais en fait bon après
j'ai pas la prétention de faire changer
d'avis mais mais tout simplement que en
fait la haine de l'autre n'est pas un
programme politique je veux la guerre
civile n'est pas un projet politique le
racisme c'est un délit c'est pas une
opinion et du coup un raciste c'est un
délinquant pain président tout
simplement pour moi ça se résume à ça
moi je suis d'abord il a des idées
dangereuses a été condamné cinq michi
condamné et je comprends pas dans
certains métiers on demande un casier
judiciaire vierge mais on est tout à
fait en accord avec tout même si on est
bien un homme avec un casier judiciaire
qui a été condamné plusieurs fois autour
tara boivent ça a été condamnée
récemment
commencé par se ressembler nos derniers
mois
on n'est jamais que c'est un mec de von
arx et bien sûr il ajouté aux élections
et là où tu vois tu me réduit à ma
religion parce que tu as commencé par là
et ben moi je pense aux valeurs
françaises les travaux devraient
commencer par ça t'a vu à ta tu as vu en
moi en voile et une femme musulmane
c'est tout ce que tu as vu mais j'ai une
française et j'ai un cerveau n'en
déplaise à certains ménages n'ont pas
encore atteint car ça dans leur tête
mais chaîne française et réfléchi avec
les valeurs françaises abc langage est
arrêté et c'est avec pardon mais jamais
puisque bref c'est pas avec l'essai pour
les valeurs françaises justement que je
suis contre zemmour c'est pour la france
et qu'on me dit monsieur verdès j'ai mal
à ma france que j'attends tout ce que
vous dites honnêtement alors inquiétant
alors alors matthieu delormeau moi je
vais dire deux choses la première juste
parce que je suis un petit peu sur un
petit peu choqué la première déjà
l'historie de quoi badiane l'histoire a
montré que tous les pays qui avaient élu
l'extrême ça c'est toujours ma terminé
ça c'est dans l'histoire mais au delà de
ça c'est vrai qu'on parle de la sécurité
c'est important mais pardon j'ai parlé
aussi un tout petit peu de 2,2 nous
aussi de ce que je représente aussi je
pense qu'on a peu près 15 % du cmo
sexuelle en france par les femmes je
rappelle que ce monsieur est contre le
mariage homosexuel il est contre la gpa
il est contre la différence
l'enseignement de la différence dans les
écoles ça veut dire que à ses yeux déjà
nous un évènement constitution pourra
pas été celle ci comment et pas non mais
dis dramé ccc socialiste bien sûr ce
sont ses idées
opinions et ce qui me fait le plus mal
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on appelle ça a été
un tel un tel combat pour avancer que je
sois contre le racisme contre
l'antisémitisme ou pour l'homosexualité
que voir qu'aujourd'hui ils puissent
tenir des propos homophobes en toute
liberté et que ça ne choque personne si
en plus c'est jean michel tu as raison
tu penses que c'est 45 % au second tour
ce sont des gens qui votent par
conviction alors j'ai très
complet oui bon on parle beaucoup du
fond des idées des risques des mots on
parle pas beaucoup de la forme et en
fait quand on nous dit qu'il est très
cash qu'est ce qui veut dire par là au
delà du fait qu'il affirme haut et fort
ses idées c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui
s'exprime de manière intelligible eric
zemmour est malgré sa grande culture
quand il parle on comprend emmanuel
magat énormément de télé mais emmanuel
macron je suis désolé ses derniers
discours notamment sur le coup vite par
exemple qui duré 40 minutes je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui comprenait
rien et voilà je pense que c'est
important
il s'adresse il s'adresse à toutes les
tranches de la population et ça c'est
très important sur la forme et je sais
pas si vous souvenez il ya six mois on
l'avait reçue quelqu'un sur ce plateau
qui avait écrit un livre c'est la
tentation du clown bah là on y est c'est
un clown politique qui rompt avec le
système qui casse les codes et qui veut
briser l'ancien monde qui est symbolisé
par des candidats alors marine le pen et
malak et surprenez vous qu'on puisse
voter eric zemmour c'est intéressant ce
qui se passe sur ce pathos on a vraiment
des opinions très divergentes libera oui
c'est à eric zemmour au deuxième tour tu
flippes pourquoi je flippais c'est un
grand mot tout le monde dit qu'il fait
flipper qu'il ya plein de gens qui
disent vous aider il nous fait peur mais
en fait c'est pas ça qui m'inquiète gpus
l'heure pour la france que j'ai peur de
zemmour en fait j'ai peur que mes
libertés pas qu'on m'enlève ma liberté
concrètement et j'aurais bien demandé à
nice l'a choisi ton prénom pour 2022 bas
une croatie mais
il s'appelle l'indicé insee du courant
sans
pareil l'ati un mépris il parle de
changer les prénoms en soit c'est une
oasis fondé non non tu peux mettre en
musulman en deuxième prénom en attendant
faut il appeler par son nom de musiciens
d'amérique c'est du
non mais et c'est surtout en parts de
calendrier alors que toute la journée on
nous bassine la laïcité la laïcité de
jupons à la laïcité quand il faut taper
sur les musulmans mais tradition
française quand il faudrait réhabiliter
pardon
ddd comment dire à des convictions
politiques puisque républicaine ces
condamnations
traitement j'ai une régie fléchir oui
oui elle est une question de davie est
ce que vous avez lu son livre à eric ses
mots son dernier derrière yannick
dernier livre son dernier j'ai eu le
premier sexe vous assure les parties
mais peut-être que vous changerez d'avis
parce que c est jeune et peut-être que
vous avez vous avez le temps de faire
d'autres réflexions son dernier livre il
parle que des restos qui fait avec des
responsables politiques sur livre j'en
avis le problème et c'est toute la
pensée d'eric zemmour c'est son problème
ils parlent tous de resto il parle
jamais des gens qui ont faim c'est ça le
problème de bascher exe mots jamais il
va vous dire qu'est ce que je vais faire
pour les pauvres qu'est ce que je vais
faire même pour les français alors on
les y quand il est bien les nobélisés
savez pour les gens par exemple qui
demande ticket qui reçoivent pas leurs
aides sociales alors qu'il devrait les
avoir qu'est ce qu'ils proposent il
propose rien il en train de tous il en
train de tomber
anissa n'y a ni devrait avoir sur examen
castaldi et delphine da fine audrey non
effectivement le problème que j'ai avec
eric zemmour si j'ai l'impression un peu
dans le dans le buzz et c'est simple si
ça sans problème en fait ça manque de
nuance dans ses idées et je trouve que
c'est dommage on sait qu'on en pense pas
quasiment mais qui fait beaucoup de
bosses pour eux voilà pour se faire voir
pour sa part l'élu est aujourd'hui c'est
parce qu'on attend d'un président et
c'est dommage voilà ne vous seriez pas
pour lui vous
j'avais oui j'aurais dit non tu as son
zemmour s'est trompé oui donc on pensait
que trust un clown et qu'ils n'y
arriveraient pas de bilan il est arrivé
bien sûr en fait c'est une journée une
punchline une polémique et tout le monde
mais courent après c'est le maître des
horloges aujourd'hui de 6 ans oui mais
voilà tout le monde est resté fixé mais
qui
gérait déjà envie d'un truc deuxième
trou si on additionne les mots et marine
le pen c 32 % exactement arrêtons de
prendre les gens pour des cons main sur
des salons pour des racistes alors des
italophones et à un moment donné il va
falloir se concentrent été trouvé sur
les gens évoquent l'arrivée d'eric
d'état vous reste plus qu'à loire
ténébreux blair qui veulent les gens ont
choisi ses rayons ici on ne donnera
jamais de leçon pour qui voter on n'est
pas à la place des gens chacun vote en
fonction de sa vie et de ce qu'il
ressent ça sérieux alors main les
donneurs de leçons qui dit il faut pas
voter ainsi il faut pas voter ça juste
seul truc qu'on peut vous demander celle
aller voter et prenez votre destin jeu
en trouverez jamais dire que c'est des
gens comme m
voilà oui et ça va faire pschitt mais en
revanche il faut arrêter de le
diaboliser il fallait le dire il est
raciste oh ben ça va taper
terminant je pense commencer je pense
que tous les vieux politiques tous les
jeunes qui sont à la ramasse d'autres à
l'aller et qui ne comprennent rien
actuellement se disent laisse le avancé
ça va faire pschitt iba redescendre et
je pense qu'ils se trompent complètement
parce que là il est arrivé à un tel
niveau que même s'il redescend il va
peser énormément dans l'échiquier
politique
il va falloir faire avec lui
madonna au final il faut être sérieux
sur l'islam et expo
2010 apporte quoi parce que quand il dit
par exemple l'immigration légale et
illégale 0 hemani migration légale 0 ça
n'est pas possible concrètement ça n'est
pas possible oui surtout beau juste
la preuve c'est qu'on en total décalage
c'est qu'à la sortie du du fameux débat
jean luc mélenchon eric zemmour jean
lépine un chien ont sorti angers gagné
j'étais meilleur jeu des mille îles est
mis face à ses contradictions quatre
jours plus tard il a fait + 3 et lui a
fait au moins 4 mai donc
je vais expliquer il a eu un petit
sursaut après le débat ça certes assez
mais c'est pas le plus important les
gens s'en foutent un peu de
la question tu peux vous dire pourquoi
ouais vous dire si vous ne vous rendez
pas compte de l'importance de sondage
pourquoi ce sondage il est très
important et l'eczéma il a 17 % qu'est
ce qui va se passer marine le pen ça ça
reste qui va se passer c'est que vous
allez avoir marion maréchal-le pen qui
va dire dans quelques jours ou quelques
semaines je vais rejoindre eric zemmour
parce que maman c'est quoi vous allez
avoir haussé de droite de la droite
républicaine et régionales et jal a dit
il devrait y en avoir d'autres vous
allez voir qu'ils vont dire à nous aussi
on va rejoindre eric zemmour et qu'à un
moment eric zemmour il va se retrouver
un jour lui qui ne pensait même pas
avoir et pourquoi ils vont venir ils
vont pas venir parce que eric zemmour il
aime bien sa coiffure ou ses chemises
ils vont venir ainsi la 17% qui hésitent
à le gagner est-ce que c'est pas le gars
qu'il peut gagner le bon chemin en
politique c'est curieux mais on suit le
vent relations
committee on a eu envie de gagner mais
son voyage de choses il ya deux choses
déjà vous remarquerez qu'il suffit de
17% pour être au second tour où là c'est
ça donc c'est un de sondages mais c'est
ça qui est grave luc mélenchon il a fait
19 % de m
c'est pour ça qu'on a fait le débat
c'est pour dire mais la france ça n'est
pas ça y'a pas de france sans les
français tous les français et que le
modèle de zemmour parce qu'il l'a fait
récemment il s'est rendu que vous avez
10 et 30 il s'est rendu dans un autre
pays sans hongrie norman la hongrie
depuis le cac et la présidence durban
ils ont perdu deux cent mille habitants
bien sûr en hongrie ils sont passés à
l'extrême boittin voilà non son
dirigeant d'extrême droite
toujours dans les nuances vous voulez
dire un truc déjà par rapport à trump
c'est tout con
preco vide trump c'est zéro guère moins
de chômage droguée moins noir que fait
la police que ce obama tu peux laisser
et surtout des chiffres économiques et
ça ça fait cinq ans de paix aussi et son
fameux muslim ban qui a été baptisé miss
nîmes vannes par la presse d'ailleurs
puisque par exemple je vais pas y aller
par l'algérie dont elle gère est un pays
musulman algérien je pouvais me rendre
aux états unis agissent vous y êtes allé
je pense femmes 0 guerre voilà
comme ça on peut pas on peut pas et on
peut passer des chevaliers avant qu vide
les états unis étaient dans une
situation économique précaire d'accès
voilà on va passer une heure oui non
mais moi je j'entends tout ce qui se dit
depuis tout à l'heure cherche un peu
surpris ou sait on à se doit et on a
deux types d'immigration là sur le sur
le plateau ben moi je on a une
préférence devant vous je préfère oui
mais c'est d'accord mais moi je préfère
les brunes locataires je préfère
l'immigration évidemment qui est à ma
gauche plutôt que l'inertie
vous attendez le projet moore défend
effectivement la france or le peuple
français c'est celui qui a construit
toutes les institutions qui protège vos
droits qui vous permet d'être libre
individuellement humourdedroite
nos droits d'accord donc c'est un pays
qui a été construit par un peuple qui
est un peuple français qui existent
d'accord ne venez pas nous dire la viéle
attise la haine etc aujourd'hui la rn1
aujourd'hui la haine et les ou qui sait
qu'ils traitent les autres de coûts
phare qui c'est qui dit nique la france
qu'il sait qu'ils attaquent les gens en
enlevant sa langue ou
sexuelles
merde les femmes ouvrez les yeux un
moment c'est certainement mais s'est
fait mal à l'épaule et les robert qui
emmerdent les
réponses
et
c'est maladroit mais c'est factuel je
dirai
juste l'idée à la banque non merci mais
réponse mercredi 3 milliards au final il
ya les les violences les violences
contre les femmes c'est dans la famille
d'accord nokia dérobert iliad et mohamed
est assurée
par la cie ouvert que c'est pas la garde
et ses missions
la gare de saint-denis
heureux
non bien sûr à nice merci de ces
messieurs alors je voulais vous dire
tout d'abord que vous aimez beaucoup
argué la condition féminine et vous la
défendez vous la défendre et bien
d'ailleurs contre booba c'est ce que
vous lui reprochez aussi que qui
dénigraient les femmes mais comment vous
pouvez voter contre quelqu'un qui les
dénigrent au même titre même pire here
is the wall a quand même dit que le
pouvoir il doit rester entre les mains
des hommes parce que les femmes ne
regarde pas le pouvoir il s'évapore dès
qu'elle arrive t il prête aux femmes
mais c'est la femme qui sont dans le
monde de 10 ans allemand de politique
comme un dire de ce rapport public voilà
il expliqué c'est arrivé au pouvoir par
des parts des voix pas très catholique
si je puis dire et vous apporte à
défendre ardemment fait qu'ils du tout
bon pour vous répondre la première chose
c'est que ma pensée n'est pas la
décalcomanie de celle d'eric zemmour
mais bon on était un petit peu pas dire
chose c'est que erin wasson exerice
zemmour il est dans la réflexion c'est
comme l'histoire il est il est dans la
réflexion donc il avance ça on peut en
débattre tout est sujet à dos contenant
d'un point début août où tout est sujet
à débat là on est d'accord [ __ ] mais si
ces prédictions du nez par des tiques
eric zemmour sur la position des femmes
quand vous portez le relais je sais pas
la réponse il vous plait 2010 tommy eric
zemmour il le dit souvent c'est ce qu'a
dit jean messia il dit souvent tu lui il
n'est pas idiot n'avancera des idées il
est dans la nanny voilà c'est ce qu'il
dit ça c'est assez malin de sa part qui
dit non mais je me suis amusé il viendra
parler gervais nathalie je suis pour
discuter de ça pour une autre est-ce que
je peux juste dire monsieur mais ça
c'est bien ses danseuses et grave dans
boy et vous le dit depuis des mois sur
les agrès je suis très content d'être en
face de vous pour vous répondre
alors vous essayez vous essayez le reste
a dit fier en m'expliquant que parce que
je porte un voile je veux pas défendre
les femmes et c'est justement parce que
je les porte et que je défends la
liberté pour tous de se vêtir comme il
le souhaite les francs des charges
français me croit les bronzés me croient
plus que vous comme ça fait des mois que
vous êtes chez les cathos bouzid des
choses franchement qui nous dit vous
dites des choses vous vous répétez
d'être un disque rayé vous êtes les
zemmour de wisches mais vraiment
[Applaudissements]
la loi m'autorise à porter mon voile et
c'est pas vous qui allez m'interdire la
loi et les valeurs françaises et les
lois républicaines mais que vous
défendez temps elle mais l'autorisé vos
convictions elles ne sont pas au dessus
de la constitution madame non mais j'ai
jamais d'abord j'ai jamais été libre et
nous avons le droit d'avoir les avis sur
tout y compris d'être contrôles
tatillons déplaise ne vous en déplaise
bien sûr mais c'est à didier pas sur le
disque ans au drame c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est que ils
pourraient être français il ne suffit
pas simplement de respecter respecter la
loi bref sinon je suis né je pourrais
être amérique et là je pourrais être
algérien juste parce que je respecte les
lois de ces pays un pays c'est aussi une
identité d'accord c est en france il ya
quelque chose de très qui n'est pas
écrite dans la loi mais qui fait partie
de notre identité ça s'appelle la
discrétion religieuse on se bat là sa
passion du ballon il avait 6 millions
sans se balade pas égaler le magen de
david qui couvre sa poitrine voilà c'est
comme ça donc hier à gaza mais sans
folie est une autre illustration et je
vous dit que le cas français mais vous
êtes vous chez seafrance vous aimez vous
êtes un billet communes françaises
[Musique]
c'est que c'est à dire mais vous
insultez madame moi je les voulais bien
faire mais vous insultez madame et
j'assume je sois je serai défendent tous
et sont choisis mélangeant c'est son
choix madame mais c'est légal s'ils
n'avaient pas le droit de dire s'il
allait salibïa chute aux gens s'ils
n'ont pas de sortir déjà ya personne qui
a parlé de vol vous me renvoyez
directement à ça alors que je suis plein
de jolies mais c'est pas grave on
fait face à wade de course et religieux
j'avais laissé des jo répondre merci ça
non mais france lui élever vos mots et
par votre voix parce que c'est vrai on
est dans un débat laisse parler les gens
ça
me tombe dessus j'ai droit d'avoir sa
tombe de seigne actions que vous semblez
ignorer donc prenez des notes c'est la
laïcité l'article 1er de la mx-5 la
république à la sur la liberté de
conscience elle garantit le libre
exercice des cultes point final j'espère
aloi mais vous me
laissez les parler de minutes l'ia parce
que tu as fini bah je pense c'est à dire
un truc je voudrais que tu rappelles que
thé tiem but était déjà venu dans cette
émission toi c'est toi qui a choisi de
porter ouais mais ça franchement on
avait un deal ou parce que oui mais
aimer ses deux fils que je dois dire que
oui c'est ça et c'est ce que je vais
demander si vous êtes supporter faire
ses parts et votre vos lunettes je
voulais pas demandé non mais bon c'est
je joue ici je suis obligé parce que je
vois pas sinon
il faut chez vous et c'est autre chose
chez zemmour msyah la team rocket là
c'est toujours les mêmes discours c'est
des gens qui prétendent connaître
l'histoire du pays relatives à leurs
précédents changer la france la loi de
1905 monsieur messia si vous vous
replonger un peu dans les archives vous
saviez que vous sauriez que vous vous
engagez il a raison il ya eu un débat y
avait un débat à l'assemblée entre sûr
il y en a qui disait faut interdire tous
les signes religieux d'accord y en a qui
disait ça dans la rue partout il en faut
plus et y en a d'autres aristide briand
et d'autre ce qu'on fait cette loi de
1905 qu'on dit non non les amis on va
pas aller jusque là parce que la loi de
1905 ce après des siècles de guerre
civile et on va tous se calmer la
pression elle va redescendre et on va
vivre ensemble et vous voulez vous
voulez pas vivre ensemble c'est ça
continue je n'aime pas manger
nous voulions aller bien porter juste
par exemple justement pour bien montrer
que voilà ce que monsieur messaadi par
rapport au voile et j'adhère pas à 100%
mais je suis d'accord avec lui et a le
droit de penser ce qu'ils pensent mais
la différence est bien
servi que tu fais comme si
d'accord mais bref est incroyable
finir leurs invectives pas l invective
pagnon messia c'est que jean-michel il
faut lui dire si pour arrêter de les
surcharger donc on est obligé des
docteurs en islam carrément même en
arabie saoudite des oulémas est ce que
c'est qu'un élément qui le leprechaun
aux ajustements qu'il faut manier l'art
ça oui al azhar par exane espoir ma
d'enlever son voile si par exemple ou
quand tu es dans un pays non musulmans
si ça ne favorise tendance action en
fait là on n'est pas sur un des bateaux
dit donc senna parfois
quand je veux dire c'est qu'en fait il a
promis la niçoise problème c'est pas
faire supporter qu'on t'attend jugeant
qu'à nantes c'est une bonne chose c'est
me féliciter pour des surdités
franchement
mais voilà c'est bon c'est bon ouais ce
que je vais dire je pense pas que ce
soit des musulmans en tant que telle ou
les lois de l'islam comme c'est leur
problème s'il est ce que les musulmans
soient visibles parce que quand vous
avez des femmes de ménage qui porte le
ballon vous en papier on vous entend
jamais céder vous voyez une femme une
femme une assesseurs un bureau de vote
quand tu participes à un syndicat je les
ai justement c'est bien sa grossesse
qu'elle entend dire bah oui ce que
certaines
femmes voilées canada
parce que là où vous parler
d'intégration c'est à dire il ya des
générations en arrière moi j'en suis à
me demander quel est mon ma valeur
ajoutée la société mois elle c'est à
dire intégration on a dépassé vous êtes
vraiment péril non non non pas du tout
vous n'êtes pas ni intégrés n'y en soi
ça me désole voulais pas qu'ils allaient
merci